[Music]  congratulations on everything I'm in the  show I mean everything you got going on  it's very exciting talk a little bit  about being here supporting your fellow  actors it's amazing I mean the show  monarch I just can't believe that we've  written nine seasons are two under the  episode just aired it's insane well we  love you and Welles on social media  together you guys for many people a  couple's goals for sure what's what's  that you've heard that before  yeah the couple goal thing I don't know  it's like a hashtag what is it about you  two you think that just sort of makes it  work I don't know any any couple that  hosts a picture of them like eating  pizza  people are gonna say couple goals the  relationship goes like that's I I don't  think I don't think we do anything  different I didn't think we're just like  any normal relationship is the best  answer  [Music]